Greetings. Be sure to pick up the handout.
That's that tells them about Mundy's notes.
And I guess I'll wait until a few more people walk in before I remind you that the homework is done a week from today.
But since you you all did come on time, I want to show you something that I think is fun to start with.
This is a an example of of of a literary genre that I just wanted to give as a group, as a very good example of of of being in its form.
So here's a little short story. And I was sitting in my office cleaning the debris out of my 38 and wondering where my next case was coming from.
I like being a private eye.
And even though once in a while I've had my gums massage with an automobile jack, the sweet smell of greenbacks makes it all worth it.
But doesn't that capture a certain style of writing about us optimally as possible?
If you were if you were told to write a Sam Spade type of mystery story is there, but is there a better way of of you know,
I mean, this is almost as good as Raymond Chandler and, you know, the sweet smell of greenbacks makes it all worth.
Not to mention the dames, which are a minor preoccupation of mine that I rank just ahead of breathing.
That's why when the door to my office swung open,
a long haired blond and Heather Butkus came striding in and told me she was an Chappuis annuity model and needed my help.
My celery glands shifted into third.
She wore a short skirt, tight sweater and a figure described a set of parabolas that could cause cardiac arrest in a year.
You recognize the author yet? What can I do for you, sugar?
I want you to find someone for me. Missing person. Have you tried the police?
Not exactly. Mr. Lopa with call me Kaisers Sugar. Oh, all right.
So what's the scammon God? That's right. She wants you to find God for me and so on.
And it's a this is a great short story.
Oh yeah. I had some fruit up in the office before, but when they're built like she was you listen.
This style is you know, I just think it's a wonderful piece of writing.
And let's see. Well, I opened the deck of Luckies in a pack of gum and had one of each.
This. Oh, well. So anyway, it's the missing person case.
And she ended and it actually comes up through the rock. This is by Woody Allen.
And. And I when I when I looked at it, it seemed to me, you know,
and if you if you close it again and try to and just try to try to recap or reconstruct the first paragraph or try to think of how you would do that,
that again, to start to to make that, you know, you start out in the detective's office and he does something tough.
Nobody talks a certain a certain certain jargon and so on.
But this this to me, captured it more beautifully than now in India in your term papers.
I want you to have as a genre in mind. I don't I don't necessarily want it to be a detective story or or anything like that.
But the point is that there are there are many kind of recognizable writing
patterns and and whichever one that you whichever one that you that you choose,
you try to do try to do a good job in that in that in that style.
I'm not I'm not saying do long term paper in such that that would be interesting to try
to rewrite some of these some of these math expositions in different different ways,
I guess. But I have have one in mind that you that you're trying to do, that you're trying to do well.
And today I'm trying to talk about a Web message on her computer programs explanation as they're trying to as.
And trying to see some of the characteristics that can improve that.
And her Wilf will be our guest speaker on Wednesday, said he wants to show you a example of doing one proof two ways.
Why that would be, too,
if you were describing it to specialists versus describing it to undergraduates and how you would approach the same the same problem.
Two different points. I would take my sweater.
Yeah, I got a computer science T-shirt on. And if I see this, I'd have to show this.
We'll wait a few minutes. Well, I was sitting in my office cleaning out the debris out of my 38.
OK, now let's see. Remember then homework is due a week from today.
No excuses for late homework accepted. Please do your best on that.
On that. And as you can, you can plan that you're writing it for somebody who's at the level of a reader of a math journal,
or you can pretend that you're writing it for an undergraduate or something like that depends on on your own preference.
But I would be very interested in seeing the best possible solution to that problem,
because I plan to send the best ones to to Gilman for his information at the end.
And we'll see. And so don't let me down. How about a computer program next, exposing computer programs?
There's also an aspect of using using web that encourages you to write better programs that I wanted to I wanted to mention.
We have the we have the program broken down into parts and each part has a certain focus to you know, each module has a certain focus to it.
Now, when I'm writing a computer program, not in ordinary language, Pascal.
See. Or something like that. And I tried to make that program look like a program that I'm proud of.
So that after the program is written, it's supposed to the program is sort of still supposed to please me in some way.
I like to enjoy what I do anything now. So it's now good style of programing.
If I'm writing a program that's gonna be used for a lot by a lot of people is to have
a lot of checking and recovery from errors that might be present in the input data.
But that take that actually takes a large percentage of the code. I mean,
people say that the should be at least 25 percent of a good piece of software is is entirely devoted to recovering and from from errors
made by the user trying to give helpful messages and things like that and and the rest of it does the actual job of the program.
But but a lot of it is devoted to error, recovery.
But on the other hand, when you're writing a program in an ordinary language, typically you come to a part where you want to write a little procedure.
And the job of the procedure is to is to do some some task about the data.
I guess I won't be specific. I'll just be abstract. But this just this procedure is supposed to do something.
On the other hand, the data could also be wrong. So if you if you do the kind of error correction that you really ought to do,
we turn out that that that you have this short procedure and it looks and it has 50 lines of code about error correction,
and it has one line of code that actually does the thing. That's correct.
If if the data is wrong and somehow it looks like the whole purpose of this procedure is to give
an error message and that that and that psychologically that doesn't appear right in your code.
You see this procedure sitting there and it looks like it's giving an error message.
So you find suddenly in order to make this procedure look correct,
you're trying to shorten the code that does the error message as much as much as possible.
And you and you don't really get get very, very enthused about about doing a very beautiful error recovery for the person,
because that would just that would make the program look wrong to you. So Web changes this because it's in Web.
You write the procedure and the procedure and. And in the module, let me know.
You say what the procedure does and then there's a little line in there, says,
check if data is wrong and then that that check is in some other module.
But that doesn't take up much space.
And so you can see as you see the procedure code, it looks like the procedure doing the right thing that's supposed to do to the data.
Well, then you get to this other module where where you're actually checking the data for errors and make an error message.
But now that's on another page. But that's in a place where your whole purpose of that page is to make the best error message you can.
So you're encouraged as you're writing that other module to do your best job of error correction.
And and so it turns out that that it looks good now to make a good error correction in your program and therefore you make a better one.
And I found that this is that this is true a very surprising extent.
And comparing programs that I wrote before and after using the web system and and comparing.
Also, I have programs that were written by by some of the top system programmers at Xerox and so on,
that that I started out thinking they were great programs. And I know I took the program after we put it on the Web.
And I found that I would actually be doing. Better job of you of Erica.
Ever. Erica covering correction because of this, this fact. OK.
Now, here's here's a small example of that that occurred in the program by the freshman here where he has a little procedure called Hex Hex do it.
And he's converting a hexadecimal two digit hexadecimal number to an integer.
And so he has a or not a single one digit one character.
And so he is checking if it's the or the if the character is is larger than the capital A.
And that's code. Then he checks it at less than F F and then he gets the converts at other.
But otherwise he has this char error. And then, you know, if it's not a letter then he looks between zero or nine and makes an error.
Now most freshmen giving them the programing assignment wouldn't have had that error detection in there.
And you can do it. You can cha or you could compress also into one one macro.
And he he and I suggested they he forgot to assign a value to this procedure in that case.
So. So the small change. But but since he was the only student who could look for errors in the input data,
I gave him credit for that and reminded me about another fact that went.
Now, here's the one by I think this this man was a junior.
And and I found that his first job in in Webb was quite easy to read.
And and I just so I didn't have as many comments about the.
I had to change switch to that stuff is to have to do that.
But at the very beginning,
he he had a comment called place here because placed here because Tangle insists that's he's commenting
that he has had to make a definition here before it was used because Wetangula s a Web program.
That's that comment was completely uncalled for to criticize the Web in a document like this.
So, so much better to have a have a comment saying the total number of vertices.
And so I think you can get there's.
I and and I was then he and he used lowercase letters for the names of sections and I suggested uppercase in them and so on.
And and here's a place where we're winning, referring to that, you know, at the edge from A to B.
He he it there's a you should use the same type of graphic style when you refer to a variable as.
So you should. So in in Webb you put vertical lines around something if you want it to be formatted
as it would be in the middle of a program instead of in the middle of a sentence. And so so that will that.
So that was a small typographic chain.
Here's here's a case where he said he has a string if C is an equal D. then merged the components of A and B, and that was the wrong column.
I mean, he is really merging C and D instead. And we don't appear in the the actual code.
So. So a better title would be to have to have C and D in the title corresponding to the variables that are actually there.
But it is pretty good I think was pretty good. The problem here was Duke.
Well, he I mean, he's had a very nice but he immediately caught the idea of giving good comments at the beginning of his modules,
explaining the intuition behind the steps instead of a play by play.
So he says, you know, he needs so he he gives an analogy between, you know,
I'm not going go into details of the algorithm, but he has a nice way of of saying this.
And now here he gets into it. We can further flattened trees as follows.
And by this time, the reader knows what it means to be flattening a tree and why you want the platinum tree and so on.
Then he says, we accomplish this through the magic of tail recursion. And this would be for certain readers.
This would be this would be an interesting comment.
Tale recursion is a is a is a magical computer science technique that says that at the end of at the end of a recursive procedure,
the last thing you do is, is we call the procedure again.
And so the procedure reduces to itself. And tell recursion is a case where at the tail end of your job, you record your recurse.
But unfortunately, this is not a tale example of Cal recursion.
So the comment was didn't didn't reflect the the algorithm.
This is a recursive procedure, recursive procedure that Wepa.
But we tell recursions specific. No, I don't know, maybe they teach you tell recursion means something else.
Stanford undergrads, I don't know. I hope not. But there is a non recursive solution actually for this particular problem.
Would be better, but it would have been a nice commun if it had been correct. A small point here.
He said he had no read read from his data file left and here.
His comment was read left. Then it would be better to be redundant there and say lattitude say.
So you reinforced the idea that this was lattitude minutes reading longitude.
Second. Secondly. And then also I would add the comment, ignore rest of line because there was more stuff on the line.
And he's using a statement that does that. So the comic could, you know, can be improved slightly, but pretty much he's got the self.
So most of these comments that I made, there were four for twiddles. And so for his first program, it was quite good.
The second program I got off a few months later and he still had to change, which to that a few times, but.
Yeah. But the other strange way of starting, though, it wasn't the best, the best beginning.
We will soon construct a graph out of the distances between a hundred and twenty eight cities.
The problem that is working, I was kind of interesting.
We have data that comes out of the standard, a standard mileage guide that was published for for the trucking industry in the 40s.
And it's actually used for for many years. They do it with computers now.
But for many years, people would look up in this book and they would find out how much how far it is between City X in Sydney.
Why and and that would be the basis of your charge for for the cost of shipping.
And. And so all truckers had his books and AMSO and we made a database from this book by taking one one fourth of the data.
We took 128 of the cities and all the distances between those cities and put them into a machine.
And we were going to use this to solve traveling salesman problems and things like that.
Now, the strange thing is that we found that data was very flaky and and many cases
where where the things would be hundreds of miles off in the in this book.
And so we wanted to figure out a way of of making the fewest patches to the data that would that would still make it reasonable.
And. And so this is where his program is trying to sell now.
So he talks about the triangle inequality, for example.
Now, the distance from A to B is usually less than it should be, less than or equal distance from A to C plus distance from sea to be because.
Why should it? Why should it be a thousand miles from from one city to another?
If you if by going through another city you could do better. You could only if you could do it.
It's five hundred miles by going by going through city C of course,
maybe city C is New York City and you don't want to go through New York City or maybe Manhattan Island.
It's you know, it might be a shortcut from four miles, but not from me, not not from some other points of view.
So we could we could realize a few a few violations of the triangle, inequality like that.
But there were. But we still wanted the data to satisfy the triangle inequality that we that we finally gave.
So we so we were going to, too. I mean, my idea in this whole project is to publish these these datasets so that researchers at
different conclusions can compare their their algorithms on combinatorial problems with it,
with using common data. And the only way to do that right now is on random data, which doesn't seem to reflect reality.
So we want to use some real data for this purpose. Here's a man from our department agreed that this might be useful thing.
There's similar databases for linear programing problem integration for us.
I just think that's something I've kind of been wondering about in the past.
I'd like to see a lot of examples of an algorithm running on some natural data and how you if you're presenting an algorithm and the data,
you know, how you can combine figures or whatever.
So that just to show the show the way an algorithm runs out to show something.
Yeah. Show how it acts. Okay, I'll try. I'll try to remember to bring something like that in because this doesn't give much output.
This is mostly, you know, this is just how we massage things. Yeah.
The best actually for that is that is that it is algorithm animation which is which is instead of giving a book, you give a.
Set. And, you know, and they run it on a Macintosh or whatever, and you see the algorithm.
I mean, no, sir. There's great advances in that are going on on there.
So. But what's the name of the system that's supposedly coming out now?
Frame or something. But a people.
It was a what? No, no. That's a company. But there's also a piece of software that that the guy from ground is is up is about to finish anyway.
But it's something, OK? There's some ways that I think Mac Paschi, some ways to to sort of see that the thing as it's running.
I haven't experienced that myself, but there's. But my.
But Bob Sedgewick was a pioneer. This in a course at Brown about five years ago, where he where he presented,
I guess, 20 algorithms during the course of the quarter and each one had a visual.
You could actually, you know, it was it was associate with a certain visual pattern and you could watch all he could watch different
sorting algorithms behave and you could just psych out the meaning of these much better than any other way.
I thought was pretty exciting. Well, he gave a presentation here and I'm colloquium.
But I don't know. I don't go to conferences. I'm sorry, I. It's too depressing.
There's more work to do every time I go to a conference site. I like to hide that fact from myself, but.
But conferences are usually good for most people.
But. But I haven't. I hardly ever go.
But these Congress presentations.
Well, like. Like Scott Kim from his oral exam here, he he had he made a video that was extremely successful of a lot of showing the session,
you know, demonstrating his programing with different with different inputs.
And it was done well. And he got it together in a week.
So it can take you know, I mean,
it was it was something that or I've seen a few other things like this where somebody would would take to do it with video tape recording this.
But these are these this algorithm animation picked on.
The reader can also experiment with it, you know, and play play with this thing once.
It's once it's it's there. And so. So it is software is being developed now to make this easier.
Well, it's Bob Sedgwick, however, he's now at Princeton and and he's that.
Yeah, you could be you could I think he's chairman of the permanent Princeton computer science.
But to do it in a book in a in a fro some kind of a frozen form, there is there are ways to to do that that I'd like to show you.
And we can talk about maybe doing better. But these things have been the best I was able to think of years ago.
OK. Now so I so I don't know how, how, how to fix his his openings is opening paragraph real soon.
We will soon construct the graph.
But I guess I would just, you know, go back to the old cliches about the purpose of this program is to construct a graph or something like this,
but not but after that, he got going pretty well and he had like a nice choice of of of names here, MIT villains.
He has this and he he considers that parts of the of the data are shortcuts.
And and they that would then the people.
And he you're trying to find the the most villainous parts of the data.
And so I thought that maybe he had to use Roget's Thesaurus or something,
but finding the word villains had a had an advantage that we were that a lot of the exposition
later became easier because we have other words that go with villain villain villainy and.
And somehow when it's hypothetical villainy, it's always fun.
If it's if it's real villainy, it's pretty. It's just disorienting.
But in something like this, it seems like fun and games.
OK. I guiney you've got to learn to to go in here he puts it.
He puts a lot of things in no in no proper type here.
The name LAT Lon and Miles or so on are in our in italics but then.
Every once a while, it was it was here that this is true in the Enten EMP city is given by miles of a bee.
It is a funny change.
And why do people always give n and then second, I don't know.
How many times have you at a conference or heard of talk where somebody will say and let in an M b the following variables or something like that.
What. Why reverse alphabetical order. It seems to be.
I know sometimes it throws my mind off the off the problems to think why did he reverse alphabetical order?
Is there some reason for it? OK. Look at that.
And it is that get. Now I used to do this all the time.
I mean, if you look at anything that I wrote before 1978, there'll be a three week in which is per page.
And so. But I've gotten to be very much reactionary against it here.
Here we see what happens if you if you can't really see it too well.
But this is this is a seat. What happens if you type a double quote in your file?
You get you get a closing quote instead of an opening quote.
And so that's one little little refinement to talk that when you go to author prepared type setting.
You might have to realize that there's a difference between quote marks and and let's see what happens.
Yeah. Oh, yeah. That's coming up later. So.
So people aren't used to distinguishing between open quotes and closing quotes because they're used to using a typewriter where there was only one.
And it seems as simple, you know, if we'd always had a distinction and then there would be nothing to say about it.
And I suppose a computer type setting system could could go even an odd and every, you know, look for space before or something like that.
And Judge, it's funny, in in in Germany, this is the opening quote and closing quote looks the other looks like the other one.
I mean, they, they, they, they start their quote marks that they actually they they go down below, you know, whatever here and then.
And then. Then the other quote goes this way afterwards. It's just just backward and and so,
so they probably ought to be reflected by some semantic I mean by some functional thing instead of giving the quote.
I mean what do you type in a text file in order to get this? Which directional quotes do you do?
You do if you're going into German style. How do you get people who are keyboarding manuscripts in Germany to understand the American conventions?
It's a from here.
Come on. I just said nice.
I wanted to say this was this is an example of of an very nice understanding of how to present present part of our Web program.
So I thought I'd show it to you here. Not geometrically.
A great arc is simply an arc of a great circle.
A great circle is formed by the intersection of a plane in a sphere when the plane passes through the center of the sphere.
The equator is an example of a great circle. Computing great arc distances involves converting the appropriate longitude latitudes.
First is for a recorded instant or a thing of the coordinates.
Then finding the angle between the position vectors for the two cities, the SANGALLI finds an arc on a great circle whose radius is that of the Earth.
The length of the arc is simply the angle times the radius. And now he many defines constants with symbolic names.
So he has pi and radius. And then he has a function to compute great art distances.
Now we decided that that would be one way to catch something that was definitely a blunder in the data.
If the if the shortest distance from from A to B is less than the distance on the Earth's surface,
the shortest possible distance, then we know that we have data error.
And what is another guy from Manhattan keeps bringing these things up is tunnels in New York.
I throw this stuff out. OK, yeah. And in fact, the the ratio of highway miles to create art distances is usually at least a factor, too.
I mean, they are they use these as the crow flies.
Doesn't really go to correspond to the way you have to drive.
But we. Using this idea and and I gave him some data to calibrate from what latitude
and longitude of points where I had maps of Yosemite and things like that,
where it was pretty well, it was pretty close. And this seemed to correspond.
So even though the earth isn't spherical, it was it was a good enough approximation my way that the.
But now he has a function and that computes the great distance between city and city, too.
And he declares variables which are motivated. These historic spherical coordinates, rectangular coordinates, angle and.
And then he has the body of the procedure.
Convert latitude and longitude, spiritual coordinates, converts, vocal chords through a tangle of corners,
put the angle between the position vectors and inset the great artist.
And so this was motivated. Well, I thought. And you can read this and I understand that an algorithm is good as well as anything.
And you get to the other modules in there. There you go.
So he gets to the next module about converting to spherical coordinates.
And so he defines what polar coordinates mean.
And and and talk about the radius of the earth.
And so here I here is a formula for historical cornets courts, for the displayed formula and everything.
It's nice to be able to do that in the middle of a computer program. And so it was it was I thought, well, I'll be fine.
I'm not quite sure how to take Claire.
Thanks for that use. And then they used it. Yeah.
You could you know, you can do this. This is a this is something that's three adjacent modules.
So you can easily remember if you have to if it's a longer procedure,
then then I would have made a I would have said here I would have had a save and and I would say local variables for great art distance.
And then on the next page where I needed five one five two, I would have said local variables for great art distance and I would introduce them there.
And like in the in let me show you an example. There's a long procedure in here for four breaking paragraphs into lines.
And and so.
So I have a procedure called line break. And in fact, I even start out safe.
Line break is a rather lengthy procedure, sort of a small world unto itself.
We must build it up little by little, somewhat more cautiously than we have done with the simpler procedures of tech.
Here's the general outline.
And then I give the outline of the of the thing which I had already had a whole page of motivation on the preceding page, you know, anyway.
So then here here is the var local variables for line breaking. And and at the moment this is actually global verbals.
So so at the moment I'm not using any these local variables and we're not getting into them until age 62, which is which is quite a ways beyond here.
And and so here we now motivate some of the local variables that we'll be using a lot and didn't need them before.
And then it's a C also eight ninety three point ninety three. It's going to have four local variables that are used during the hyphenation.
Now during the hyphenation algorithm and also go into the local variables.
So it's possible to capture local variables for any routine in the middle.
And this is. And how often did I do this in this program?
So I got modules named Local Variables for different procedures in as well.
So that's it. Yeah. Macro's.
It just replaces macros. And that's a very powerful little thing.
And the name of the macro, there's two kinds of back replacement.
One is with a long name like this, namable, which sort of indicates psychologically that it's code and then it's short macros,
which are these little things, like I showed you char error or something like that, which is done with the define.
And those are are small like I mean, here I'd define a whole bunch of op codes used in a in the output file and stuff like that.
So there's different. And then there's the there's another kind of define that.
Yeah. Let me show you something. There's a there's an interesting trick that the macros aren't real general.
They only have allow one parameter at the most. I care. I can talk about the stock stop bit of something and I.
And so I. And that's the certain field of a word.
And so that's the. So the most general macro I have has one one single parameter in it.
But that it's possible to do a surprising amount with with single parameters.
And I'll show you. Let me show you some of the stuff.
One of the ways that you can do that now.
Now, you know, in a more general system, you would you would you would build in a more general Mac macro capability.
But I was able to get by with with with single macros.
By the following trick here, I'll talk about char depth and I'll follow it by two parameters and.
And so char depth is a macro with one parameter.
And then when it ends with the call of char depth end, which will then pick up this another macro and and we'll give the second parameter.
So so I went when, where do I use char depth. In example I see.
Is there. It's not used very. It's, it's right close here.
So we kind of use of it our.
This is seven or eight seven oh nine.
OK. So I would.
They like in for G and why are depths of G in HD, so HD?
So and HDR parameters CHA depth has one parameter, Jean.
But it ends with a call of cha depth and which picks up the second parameter HD.
OK. So I could get the effect of two parameters without without know still implementing this whole system in two months,
which meant I didn't have to have a very real complicated parser and something.
Microsoft fusional simpler. And the other, the other trick is let's see, do all six whereas two six defined here on this show,
you want another case of a strange way of using Mac, a single macros that made them powerful enough that I didn't need something else.
OK. Twenty three. Whoops. Here I.
I do all six with one parameter and it expands into that parameter of one.
That power of two. That parameter three. And now so I could do all six and I'll put the name of another macro as the argument to do all six.
And then. And then I'll call that other macro with six different arguments.
So so I'll be able to say, OK.
So use of do all six will come up. Come along soon. Or is it here.
OK. Set. Set. Break with the background of a parameter is a.
It says break width of some of the parameters to background the parameter. Then I'll say do all six.
Set with the background. See this column.
Do all six here. Set. Break with the background. So that means I'm setting break with one to background one but with two to background two and so on.
So that was a shorthand for based only on on macros with one one parameter which would which seems to be a lot more general.
And then you in the ordinary can do is go off on that.
So so when a procedure is short, I think the right.
I think you can can remember these.
But certainly if I were designing a program, this is the most significant defect in Pascal and Wirth's when he designed Fortran trend.
He was trying to compete. I mean, Pascal was trying to compete with Fortran and.
And he was trying to get the Fortran market and his original design.
Pascal. He didn't have recursion in it. He thought Fortran programs didn't care about it.
He will want to have a cleaned up version of Fortran. And he was and he was making it look rather like Fortran at the beginning.
And then he put in recursion at the last minute when he filed it came free. But but this was.
But anyway, he he in his previous language, Algol W,
which was used at Stanford for inter teaching introductory courses for many
years and was actually one of the nicest programing languages ever in history.
The world had a great debugging system and everything go with it.
But there he allowed local variables to be declared in the middle of a block anywhere you wanted to.
And for some reason he took that out. I suppose it's back in my file again, but.
But he now insisting that all of Moka verbals redeclared up front here, which is not.
And that certainly conflicts with the way you would want to write a program when the Web programing style.
The best way would be to be able to declare them right there in the middle of the block where you're using them.
And so I'm forced to be forced to do as well as I can with Pascal as the underlying language with a better language.
I would be able to have a better exposition in this style. Yeah. Wasn't that then?
So a compilation could be one half compilation is one pass.
Yeah, he was he had this he had the compiler written in its own language and he wanted it to be.
But you can still do it in one pass. It's just made us made a similar table algorithm easier.
I mean, is the that the algorithm you had for identifier lookup was when he just wanted that to be to be a small number lines of code.
And then then he went and added the width statement some years later, which made it all very hard, OK.
But you can, you know, quick it's easy to criticize the design after the fact.
And so many things go into a programing language.
That the as I was writing tech, I would learn new things about Pascal every every few weeks and you might have heard a scream coming from my office.
You know, you can't have an array of file names or something like this. Files in standard Pascal.
In some versions you could. So I was unable to you know, I was going to use it for a system program.
But it was it was it were many things about it that were that were crying out that
they were designed only for textbook short examples and not a system program.
But, well, we have helped us surmount these difficulties by having macro's.
I could I could get around. Now having an array of files and things like that.
Well, then when was designed and another language, PR 360.
Oh, I'm running out of time. He he he he designed a language which was a symbolic equivalent of the IBM 360 machine language.
And as and that exercise taught him, you know, things about the 360 architecture that would have been that were that would have been much better,
because once you saw it in this higher level form, well, the same thing happens when you look at something through the Web form.
You look at Pascaline, you see deficiencies like this news have all been cleaned up in.
It is this subset of data is is is very well done in the past called subset of ADA is as gets rid of all the problems of Pescado.
Is it OK now. Oh announcement from the the other text has arrived in the bookstore, a handbook for scholars that.
Twenty three copies arrived yesterday and so they're all there and you can go and get what you said you went to.
They have twenty three of them there now for six to nine and 15 more on order.
So, yeah, they probably looked it up in their computer and they probably asked for the wrong thing.
OK. Now, another quick thing about this program.
Here is a case where I thought I got where I could you know, I liked his choice of word, villains and so on.
But here he has a variable called scan and and scan is a variable that's moving through.
And it turns out that when you when you study this algorithm, you don't want a verb for the name of that variable.
You want a noun. And so a word like place would have been a better call.
It places replaced because you move to the next place. But scan is not.
So somehow when you choose the names of certain kinds of variables, you want a.
Certain kinds. You one. You want a verb. Sometimes you want nouns.
But think of their function in their own little.
One other little point was the well, remove all Willams from miles.
This is the name of something we're doing, a operation that removes villain in whatever that means.
And you have to assume that this loop does it. But now then he ends that with a with something that moves his pointer to the next thing in the list.
And this this statement here, take my word for it does not have anything to do with removing villains for miles.
This is something that really should have been done in Section 32 or this code is used so.
So when you you know, this will this Pascal court will execute correctly.
But he's assuming that in Section 32, his last statement is moving this moving his pointer to the next thing as a hidden thing.
And so instead, Section 32, he's got these these removed villains from Miles Restore least Edge or something like this,
and then hidden me not not being told here. Also, move your point to the next guy,
which is which is that should have been kept out out in the calling module for what might make so much cleaner, cleaner logic.
And so that's the kind of thing that. So, so, so, so truth in naming is a is worthwhile and it's not.
The last one I want to show you is by someone who is a dual major in English and computer science.
I hope this doesn't identify him too much, but it was the most literate first use of Web that I have seen for sure.
And he's working on another kind of data set, which is based on the characters of which is the encounters between characters in novels.
And this particular one was on a Carnamah. And. And he he did two two drafts of this.
So after this after I marked this one up, he said another draft.
I, I, I commented about these these quote marks.
And I thought my comment would be specifically I mean, it's very easy to understand.
I just circle them and said, fix these. And so what he did was he he fixed them.
They change them into single quotes, both undirected. So he didn't understand what I meant.
And I wanted directional quotes there. Now he's used typewriter type.
Well, here you see refers to the file and he's using it also to refer to the data inside the file where we're talking about characters of of actually.
This is not an acronym you also used for other novels.
This is limited. You can use accents.
And when you're when you're doing this and stuff.
And I suggested here that this this data would look a little better if you shifted it over and dented it, even though in the file it isn't indented.
Still look better, I think indented now.
Hmm. But he has a nice, nice way of presenting it at the beginning, you see, because he,
he gives and he gives real data and he talks about so, so you can understand the format.
This is something that is very clear way of saying what the input looks like.
And that's really the the main thing that you want to do and in a lot of computer programs is give a good
characterization of of the of the input to your program and a good characterization of the output from your program.
That's a very important part of documentation.
Seems obvious, but so surprising how many times you see programs that that don't go into much description with typography.
You can make that description very easily, very readable and doesn't take much more time than what you were doing otherwise.
Here's the thing. Here's a suggestion I made four four four four four using Pascal in a higher level way of Pascal.
Pascal will recognize a particular idiom, pack the array of char with a certain one dot dot and and then it'll it will.
That's the way you have to represent character strings in Pascal. And so I suggested that he declared and he adopted this in this.
But you declare a macro. String type of something, compact array of char, and then everywhere in your program,
you want to put a string and now you can call it string type or something.
And so it looks it looks more like Pascal should have been in the first place.
Now he has a funny thing here way, which maybe is if it's a standard computer science, but maybe only the way they teach at Stanford.
He says he chooses the hash list to have cabooses. And then he says we we choose the component list to have engines.
And so there must be I don't know if this is something that they there's something about data processing.
I think that they haven't abandoned or never heard of cabooses engines before.
If if it's a standard term that I'm not familiar with, let me know. And then I but I took it back.
But he said he believed that there. OK. Now, here again,
I'm just suggesting you take this these and make a module of of of a module somewhere
separate for this function that a few times to breakup long piece of code.
This was his first use, the web, remember. And so here again, he had he had a confusion that somebody else had where he didn't know between it.
And we will process each line click by click and age and each character in each click, it will perform a Look-Up.
You know, we've got to be consistent there. So we must have fixed that up when he came up with a second draft.
But this. Yeah, but it's it's strictly fixed up.
So. So I think we're beginning to repeat on the kinds of things that go into computer programs.
And so maybe I've caught I've caught all the all the things here again, I want.
I said, put it begin and end. I talked about this on Wednesday. Take the beginning end.
Instead of putting them around the call, put them into the begin.
Should be here in the end. Should be here. And that works better.
The other thing that I played along with back and forth as I was as I was first programing was position of semicolons.
Should I put the semicolon in the module or should I put the semicolon call?
Finally, I decide. Finally, it was definitely working out better that I almost always put the semicolon in the call.
So I would leave the semicolon here, but the end would be at the end here.
That didn't work when I had declarations, though, because. Because if I had something like procedure declarations,
as then each one wanted it semicolon to be there so I could concatenate many declarations together.
So I had to have a dual convention for that.
If I had a programing language, if I was able to design a programing language, knowing that it would be used with a system like Web,
I'd be able to have punctuation conventions that would that would work better.
Similarly, labels in PA. he he insisted that labels be numeric and separated by commas.
I could have had something that if if he would allow us to separate them by semicolon,
I could have allowed some way to build lists separated by semicolons,
but had uses commas in one place, semicolons and other place commas between constants.
So those things meant that the high level language was wasn't able to take it back.
OK. See you Monday.